Now that we have some groovy under our
belts, we're in a much better position
to understand what's going on
inside of Gradle build script.
Just like a closure can
have a delegate object,
the entire build script
delegates to a project object.
All the keywords in the Gradle DSL
are properties of, or
methods on the project object.
For instance, the project object has a
method called task for declaring tasks.
It accepts the name of a new task and
optionally a configuration closure
which we'll talk about shortly.
If we run Gradle tasks to have a look at
all the tasks that are currently defined
we see under other tasks my
task one that we just defined.
All right.
Everything's working so far.
Because the entire build script
delegates to the project object,
we can actually go ahead and leave
that off when we're declaring tasks.
Also, because Groovy Syntax is awesome,
we can knock of those parentheses as
well, since this is just
calling a function.
Now this next part is tricky.
Gradle actually reaches into
Groovy's execution model.
And uses an advanced Groovy feature
called an abstract syntax tree
transformation.
The upshot of which is,
you can knock off the quotes as well.
This is not a thing you need
to understand super deeply,
however we do have more information in
the demo code provided with the class.
Now that we have declared a task, we can
also configure some properties on it.
So, we can give myTask4 a description,
and we can give it a group.
If we then run Gradle tasks again,
this is what we see.
Here's the group up here,
and here's the description.
The most important property
of a task is the list of
actions the task will perform.
Instead of setting the actions property
directly, we add a closure to the end of
list of actions to perform
using the do last method.
So, let's give task four a try.
Gradle helpfully tells us that it ran
myTask4, and that it went ahead and
printed the statement.
There's a few other ways to add
closures to that list of actions for
the task to perform.
We can add doFirst to add a task
on to the front of a list.
We can also use the left shift operator
which does exactly the same thing as
doLast.
This is nice because it allows us
to use this very compact syntax,
and this is what you'll see most
often when people are declaring,
very simple tasks in Gradle.
We can also declare a task, and
then immediately pass it a closure
to execute as its action.
This is an extremely common pattern,
and it's probably the most common way
that people declare simple Gradle tasks.
Instead of configuring a task line
by line as we were doing previously,
we can also pass a configuration
closure when we're defining a task.
The configuration closure
delegates to the task object.
So it can go ahead and
set the description, the group, and
the actions of the task.
Now you may have noticed something
a little bit weird about that
configuration block.
We are trying to assign
this string description,
but there's no equal sign here.
Well Gradle's actually done
something very clever.
For every property, it's created
a setter with the exact same name.
So this line is actually a function call
omitting the parentheses because Groovy.
Assignment also works just as well.
There's only one gotcha with this.
And that is, if you're assigning
a collection to a property in
a configuration closure,
you gotta use the equals sign.
Just a thing to keep in mind.
One more thing to know about tasks,
some task properties can be set in
the task declaration like this.
However, not all properties
can be set this way, so
check out the course code for
the full story.
The only time you actually have to use
this syntax is when you're declaring
a typed task,
which we'll talk about soon.